greatest oper in CSO history Kenny yes
100% homie has the most OP kills on land
but that's not even what it is bro
people don't remember bro back in 2014
2015 watching this guy do [__] like this
these kids weren't around man they don't
know this guy used to do this every fing
map this guy man was just regularly
hitting ludicrous criminal op shots
culturally he's the most important oper
that's ever lived you hit a sick no
scope to the stay you still say holy I'm
Kenny s this right here this is my
favorite Kenny clip homie drops top Hut
drops vent no scope flash out and then
he starts jiggling on get right boom
what do you even say to that dude holy
sh the way this guy instilled the fear
of God into players on the server is
just like nothing I've ever seen the
prime of Kenny S is to this day still
goed it's just absolutely crazy greatest
Opera to ever live so much damage done
here by Kenn s another frag pound and
again Kenny s